there's a story out of california now
female inmate in california is now
pregnant after uh women's prisons were
forced to accept male prisoners who
claim to be women
so this has been happening for
a few years now there's been a push
for women's prisons to accept dudes and
the phrase that's often used is
biological males they have to accept
biological males i hate this phrase
people should stop saying this phrase
the phrase biological male is a it's
itself a creation of political
correctness it's not a reaction against
political correctness it is a product of
it because the implication of the phrase
biological males is that there's some
other kind of male you know a
psychological male or a spiritual male
or no there's just men there's just men
and women okay and there's no special
caveats or categories here
so the women's prisons now have to
accept men
and this is according to a report from
the blaze
that uh women a liberal women's
organization the women's liberation
front has reported that at least one
woman has become pregnant following
california's law that lets men enter the
women's prison here's what the women's
liberation front a very left-wing
organization says quote
women incarcerated in california's
largest women's prison are describing
the conditions as a nightmare's worst
nightmare after the introduction of new
pregnancy resources in the central
california women's facility medical
clinics the new resources are a tacit
admission by officials that women should
expect to be raped when housed in prison
with men where all sex is considered
non-consensual by default within the
system
which brings me to compassion
compassion
when i was at this wedding i was
chatting with
a
very lovely gal she was
so nice i think probably
she represents what the majority of
americans feel politically which is they
don't have especially strong political
views they just want to be like nice and
on the good side and be nice to people
and not mean to people and the issue of
transgenderism came up
and she said well i just i just think
it's really we shouldn't be mean to
people we should be nice and my point as
conservatives often make is that i don't
think it's nice to lie to people i don't
think it's nice to encourage some people
to live in delusion i don't think that's
respectful at all i think that's
actually cruel i don't think that the
truth is cruel i don't think that lies
will set you free actually i think it's
the opposite
the argument for letting men into the
women's prison
is that it's compassionate these poor
men they think that they're women so we
should let them into the women's prison
well is it compassionate to the women
who are now
being exposed to some of these men could
have committed sex crimes
there's no there's no rule often barring
men from who have committed sex crimes
from coming in now this woman is
pregnant where's the where's the
compassion where is all of that
compassion compassion
can be pretty
pretty misguided and but the left is
very good at using this language of
compassion and niceness and i do think
conservatives need to get better at that
because if conservatives can't then it
doesn't matter how
strong our arguments from biology or
psychology or philosophy or theology are
people aren't going to want to associate
with conservatives i'm glad you liked
that clip i hope that you will listen to
the entire show head on over to apple
podcast or spotify or stitcher or
wherever you get your podcasts subscribe
to the michael knowles show the episode
is called destruction for us
disco for the elites we'll see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]